You should be extremely afraid.
Thank you for bringing us collectively to this moment.
It is a moment, but so many have
dreamed of claiming.
History
starts today.
The guy you work for is the evil person.
I don't work for him,
my firm works for him,  are you gonna behave yourself tomorrow?
I told you I'll do my job.
I'm a reporter.
I follow people that do not want to be followed.
What about the allegations that you recruit the most vulnerable for test that end up killing people.
Your time to go.
You're finished, mr. Brocke
Is that a threat?
You had to learn how to hide in plain sight.
I'm pretty good at it, but you,
you suck.
Whoever you are.
I work at the Life Foundation, and I need your help.
We found something, we call them symbiotes.
Carlton Drake believes that the union between human and symbiote
is the key to our evolution.
I'm feeling really sick.
I'm hearing a voice.
You're not real, you're just in my head.
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back.
I don't know
why do we do that.
If you're gonna stay you will only hurt bad people.
The way I see it,
we can do whatever we want.
Do we have a deal?
Are you willing to sacrifice
the one thing you hold most dear?
You should be extremely afraid.
What the hell are you?
We
are Venom.